this video is sponsored by nordvpn do
you want to play games like this but
don't have time to pack up and move to
japan well ditto but what if i told you
that you could just use a vpn service to
connect to the internet in japan or
anywhere in the world for that matter
from wherever you are on the globe
completely bypassing any region lock not
to mention that using a vpn in your
personal life can help to protect you
and all of your sensitive information by
blocking malicious websites and
encrypting all and i mean all of your
data like payment or login information
that you'd rather keep hidden from the
many eyes of the internet and with
nordvpn you get the absolute top of the
line vpn experience with unrivaled
speeds and connectivity with which to
accomplish all of this with just the tap
of a button no matter what device you're
using if you want to check out nordvpn
and help the channel click the link in
the description below to get an
exclusive nordvpn deal it's completely
risk-free with a 30-day money-back
guarantee if you don't like it but you
will and now on to the video
hey everyone bandit here five nights at
freddy's security breach is confusing to
quote mr matpat from game theory steel
wool seems to have just thrown a bunch
of fazbear lore stuff at a wall to see
what sticks and that is super true of
literally every location and character
in this entire game including an
infamous area room thing known as the
staff bot silo which features a bunch of
weirdly cryptic sticky notes and a small
group of staff bots seated at a table
upstairs hence its name as for the
sticky notes that may or may not have
already been solved depending on when
you're watching this video but i'd like
to turn our attention instead to the
staff bot table group now lots of
hardcore fnaf theorists have already
seen this group of bots and know what it
is that they strongly seem to represent
but for those of you who may have not
seen this area yet since the sewer area
is optional depending on how you
complete the game allow me to explain
briefly it is widely accepted that these
five staff bots represent the five
members of the afton family as in the
william afton family this is all but
confirmed for several different reasons
numerically it adds up as there are two
parents and three children one of which
is a daughter thematically it adds up as
well since the daughter very clearly is
designed to resemble circus baby who was
possessed by elizabeth afton william's
daughter and next to the baby bot is a
bot dressed up like a fazbear
entertainment employee or michael afton
william's oldest son who has been an
employee of the company on a few
different occasions and the last bot
whose head is just missing signifying it
represents the bite victim of 87 just
kidding i just said that to trigger you
i mean the bite victim of 83 also known
as the crying child also known as
william's youngest son possibly named
evan or dave or gregory it depends on
who you ask finally the gift box you can
open in the middle of this table has an
original poster from fredbear's family
diner inside which is the location where
the bite victim of 83 got bit now this
aftonbot family scene here is mysterious
and interesting but does it actually
give us anything we don't already know
what's to say this isn't just an easter
egg or perhaps that it was just the
mindless work of whoever was living in
the silo giving us information about
that person but not necessarily about
the staff bots themselves or what they
represent i'm glad you asked because
there is one very very very key detail
staring all of us in the face that
raises many questions and that is the
confirmed non-debatable existence and
representation for the first time in the
entire series of william afton's wife
mrs afton previously we only have the
theoretical connection of ballora from
sister location or the possible
representation of a cartoon character
known as clara vlad's wife in the
immortal and restless tv show that
michael used to watch after his sister
location shifts while snacking on some
much too crunchy popcorn but whether or
not ballora or clara from the show
actually serve as representations of mrs
afton is at present purely speculative
this however is not this is clearly the
afton family and that is clearly the
mother and what's even more intriguing
is the fact that each of these staff
bots are represented by actual
characters in this very game although
this is admittedly somewhat theoretical
but hey what else is new the magician
father figure is william afton the mad
murderous scientist who we can see
incarnated in this game as burn trap
underneath the pizzaplex babybot is
vanessa who is probably elizabeth afton
and sidenote for those who might have
missed matpat's recent theories going in
depth on this very subject in a nutshell
they have the same hair color the same
eye color their dads are both named
william or bill for short their last
names both start with a and they even
have the same voice actor across games
now of course the question is if vanessa
is elizabeth then how is she even alive
in a human body since she's canonically
been killed and burned as scrap baby in
the fire of fnf6 that is another theory
that's already been covered by other
people and we're getting off track at
this point so please check out matpat's
other videos if you'd like more
information on vanessa specifically
moving on the staff bot that actually
looks like staff is represented by
glamrock freddy in game who i do
personally believe has the spirit of
michael afton possessing him since after
freddy cleared the way to the
underground pizza place under command of
quote she it's entirely possible that he
came into contact with michael's body
which would have been somewhere down
here following the fnaf6 fire which
could have transferred michael's spirit
into glam rock freddy giving an
explanation as to why freddie is the
only animatronic that isn't hostile to
gregory until he runs out of power that
is
the headless staff bot also known as the
crying child is most likely represented
by gregory and once again more on that
specific theory in matpat's recent
videos every one of the staff bots has a
paired living character in this very
game so what about the mother let's talk
about it first what do we know about mrs
afton not much let me tell you in fact
we don't actually know anything about
her directly at all only details that we
can conclude from context and logical
deduction the first of these details
comes from one of the retro cds in
security breach cd number three features
vanessa talking to a therapist who says
this about her mother i know your mum
after she lost the custody case now as
annoying as it is that steel wool
decided to just leave us in the dark
with vanessa's mother's fate clearly
it's important otherwise they would have
just let us know and since it was
revealed in this game that means it
could be connected to something in this
game as well the therapist implies very
strongly that vanessa's mom's fate was
something very bad that vanessa
shouldn't blame herself for this implies
something dark happened like
incarceration or even death by suicide
and if vanessa is elizabeth then that
means that her mother mrs afton met with
some sort of terrible fate after the
court custody case now let's go back to
the staff bot silo each of these bots is
very meticulously dressed up and placed
around the table to represent something
or someone and the mrs aftonbot is no
different it's strangely seated at the
head of the table like a leader figure
instead of the father bot and it also
features a nanny looking dress in blue
hair and is known in the game files as a
nanny bot but the bigger takeaway from
the bot's appearance is the color of its
hair everything about all of the other
bots is deliberate and specific baby's
hair michael's staff clothes the crying
child's missing head so why would the
mother bot have blue hair when otherwise
it could have just looked like a normal
staff bot well i think this ties back
into another theory that i mentioned
earlier in the video that the sister
location animatronic known as valora is
meant to either represent or literally
be mrs afton ballora is the only other
animatronic or being in the entire
series to have blue hair so with
motherbot's blue hair and earrings and
the maternal design for lack of a better
term coupled with the fact that mrs
afton probably met with some sort of a
terrible fate according to vanessa's
therapy recording meaning she could have
died and possibly taken her own life i
think it might be safe to conclude that
this actually confirms the ballora
mother afton connection so here's the
next logical question to ask where is
ballora last we saw the murder ballerina
she had been scooped and added to
ennard's innards which is really fun to
say entered under control of babies
scooped michael's innards out and wore
michael's body to escape from their
sister location prison after which they
ejected out of his body at some point
and apparently went on to split ways
with babies separating and becoming
scrap baby and entered being controlled
by and becoming molten freddy keep in
mind that ballora mrs afton is still
inside of molten freddy at this point as
we can see her iconic purple eye is
still attached as we know molten freddy
was melted down and apparently destroyed
at the end of the game so bye bye
ballora right well maybe but if william
can come back and baby can come back and
michael can come back in heck even the
crying child can come back then who's to
say that ballora can't come back i mean
it's not like death by fire is a very
effective method in killing haunted
finaf animatronics am i right so we're
going to assume for this video that mrs
ballora afton survived the meltdown of
fnf6 like all the other members of her
family and is currently at large now
let's move past beloru for a second talk
about what is perhaps the most confusing
part of this confusing game and that is
the blob-like entity known as the blob
many fans equate this thing's existence
to enerd given its location in the fnaf6
pizza place which was ennard's last
location and the fact that it is similar
to ennard since both beings are melted
down combinations of other animatronics
however aside from being a tangle of
wires the blob actually doesn't have
anything in common with energ or molten
freddy molten freddy didn't have any
animatronic plates present on its body
except for a very messed up and
recolored version of the funtime freddy
mask emphasis on messed up and recolored
version and the blob instead features
the literal funtime freddy mask in its
original glory there are also the masks
of not scrap baby but circus baby the
original chica the original bonnie
mangle and the marionette none of which
were featured in molten freddy the
marionette is the only one that could
understandably have shown up here since
it was trapped within lefty who burned
at the end of an f6 in this very
location but for every other animatronic
featured here their bodies and
faceplates were previously located
elsewhere circus babies was located
underneath the sister location inside
the underground facility known as circus
babies entertainment and rentals circus
baby has already been here today and the
same goes for funtime freddy the
original chica and bonnie bodies were
located in the burned down location of
fazbear frights which was the location
of the original murders and the very
site where springtrap was created the
point is most of these animatronic
pieces that make up the blob were
previously not here and at least two of
them bonnie and chica had their spirits
set free at the end of fnaf 3 and were
no longer haunted meaning they could not
move around on their own anymore this
implies that someone must have brought
them here to either make the blob or add
to it someone that knew where the
animatronics were located including
those from the hidden sister location
now most people believe that the one
behind all the shady shenanigans in
security breach and the one who freddie
refers to as quote she is none other
than vani which would mean that vani
knows about this area down here and
subsequently the blob and even burn trap
afton himself i don't think any of
that's very hard to believe in fact i
think most people do believe that
however what i'm about to start talking
about may cause a lot of you to tune me
out for good because forewarning
everything i've talked about up until
now has just been the setup for what is
perhaps one of the craziest theories
ever created about this franchise so
please buckle your seatbelts it's gonna
get wild speaking of annie have you ever
wondered how exactly it is that she
became corrupted or possessed by glitch
trap i know there was another beta
tester from help wanted named jeremy who
went crazy and cut his own face off due
to clitchtrap's influence but that's
more of like a crazy psycho thing where
glitchtrap psychologically tortured the
poor little guy until he decided he
couldn't take it anymore i'd hardly say
that someone cutting their own face off
is proof of being possessed by glitch
trap i mean what would be the point of
that plan vanni on the other hand is
literally locked up within her own mind
and proceeds to do the will of william
afton regardless of what she may really
think about that this is possession but
how did glitchtrap who exists as a
computer virus or data ones and zeros
manage to possess a living person i mean
go ahead stick a flash drive in your
mouth and see if you can suck some data
out of it no not working didn't think so
because humans and machines do not have
a way to seamlessly transfer data back
and forth at least not yet that is the
entire reason behind spirits possessing
animatronics in this franchise it's
supernatural not scientific but i can
think of one way that glitchtrap could
possess fanny and that would be if vani
herself is a robot i know it's getting
weird now but listen let's just go full
circle with this if william can come
back as a robot after death and the
crying child can and michael can why
can't the girls in the family vanessa
and mrs afton i mean listen if vanessa
is elizabeth aka circus baby whose scrap
body is burned away and original body is
within the blob then for her to exist
here then that must mean that she's
either found another animatronic to
possess which we don't see or more
likely a fake body that she's inhabiting
just like robo gregory right i mean
matpat himself said that this sort of
terminator style fake human robot fusion
is actually a thing in the fnaf universe
according to the books and let me point
out one other detail remember that
confusing death to vani ending where
freddie football tackles her off a roof
yeah notice how after gregory unmasks
vani there's no blood to be found i mean
if vanny were human like really human
then a fall like this to the back of her
head would result in well just ask
spider-man but here she appears to be
largely undamaged and before you say
that if she were a robot the fall
wouldn't kill her remember fatty for
elvis
remember that freddy fell the same
distance right beside her and died as
well and he's definitely a robot after
the credits roll we are given another
excruciatingly frustrating scene showing
vanessa now on top of the roof gazing
down at the dead bodies of fanny and
freddie now i hear you thinking yeah
vanessa slash vandy might be a robot but
how does all this tie into ballora isn't
that what this video is about well
remember how i said that vanessa would
have to have a physical body made for
her that she could embody with her
circus baby innards wouldn't you assume
that the same would be true for ballora
if she were still alive which again i
don't see why she wouldn't be since
literally everybody else in her family
has survived in the same way up until
this point allow me to play one final
piece of evidence for the conclusion i'm
about to
you will draw me what i want and if you
fail me
then you will
both of you
notice that william afton is speaking to
a quote both of you this implies that
there is specifically not one not three
not four but two key people that are
following william afton in game now let
me turn your attention once more to that
confusing ending with vani and vanessa
it's a very widely accepted notion that
this is simply vanessa's spirit
lingering on up here still attached to
the pizzaplex implying there is
unfinished business to be had since this
ending is not actually the true ending
and this is a perfectly fine explanation
seriously no harm in believing it even i
almost believe it but allow me to raise
you another way of looking at it and
that is that this is in fact not vani
but rather vanessa and i know there are
so many signs that point to both of them
being one and the same and i agree but
certain details in this ending just make
that a bit harder to believe for me in
the first place why would vanessa's
spirit not be at her own body i mean if
you're leaving your body that implies
the starting point is your body and it's
not like vanessa is tied to the
pizzaplex she can leave and chase
gregory down to murder him outside the
pizzaplex if she chooses to also we have
a very good idea of what exactly spirits
look like in this very franchise and
they always look the same greyscale
hovering normally crying you know a
pretty classic appearance for a ghost in
popular culture add that to the fact
that vanessa is shown wearing her entire
security guard outfit including her hat
which vani was not wearing so if this
was her spirit wearing the clothes
underneath her vani costume i don't see
where her hat would have come from
unless it's actually vanessa who was
actually wearing her hat because she's
actually working her job right now also
this is the natural path that vanessa
would end up on if the building were to
catch fire and she were still inside
this is where the fire exit is located
after all and previously she was
searching for gregory inside the
building so i present you with this what
if vani and vanessa are ballora and baby
mrs afton and elizabeth who were brought
back to life with artificial bodies
designed to look like the women of the
afton family explaining why they look
similar to one another and neither of
them look their age and who were
therefore digitally corrupted by
glitchtrap in order to become his two
followers this explains the weird double
vanessa ending her facial expression
when looking down at vanni's dead body
william's forgotten trailer dialogue the
sister location animatronics being
present in the blob and most importantly
what happened to mrs afton in the series
but of course no one security breach
theory is without its fair share of
holes i mean this would directly
contradict every instance that implies
vanity and vanessa are one in the same
like this one
it is very similar to vanessa
and also
bunny which is pretty hard to argue with
and it still doesn't quite answer why
gregory would be so mercilessly hunted
down by both vani and vanessa but to be
perfectly honest with you i do think
that some lore was introduced in
security breach that will be retconned
inevitably it just simply cannot fit
perfectly right now without large leaps
of speculation that nobody actually gets
behind however with what's been
presented to us about mrs afton and the
fact that i think she should if she
doesn't already have an in-game
representative this is the best i could
do but what do you guys think is mrs
afton ballora who became molten freddy
who became vani who was also represented
by this nanny butt or is mrs afton lost
to time and vani and vanessa are indeed
the same individual let me know in the
comments below also thank you so much
for watching and if this is your first
video of mine thanks so much for being
here be sure to leave a like if you
liked the video and subscribe to stick
around for many more videos to come also
also huge thanks as always to my bandit
crew and a very warm welcome to doc t
pepper who joined at the top tier
seriously thank you so much you guys are
the reason i keep going that's all i've
got for this one so as always i hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day this
is maskington abandoned looking forward
to seeing you next time and signing out
peace
[Music]
you